i have to apologize for this question
because it's like the biggest career
question i could be asking but there's a
lot of things happening in the industry
right now that has this on my mind what
is the biggest difference in your goals
in what you want to produce from when
you first started in the industry versus
what you were prioritizing and drawn to
today given how things are shifting um
you know what when i first started in
the industry i think that because i came
at it from an independent route right i
didn't have like any hollywood pedigree
i was like interning for some big
produce i just literally did it on my
own so when i first started off it was
like how do i get a film made and get
anybody to see it like any single person
to see what i'm trying to create
now of course it's a little different
i'm in a different position i'm trying
to make movies that the masses can see
now it's not just about completing them
executing them it's like how can i do
things different and better how can i do
genres i haven't explored before how can
i work with people that i haven't worked
with yet so given that answer what is
something about beast that you know
ticks a new challenge box for you
something that might help you on future
films yeah no this is definitely my
first time working with uh doing a
survival thriller my first time working
with this much cgi uh first time being
on location for so long out in south
africa uh the on location plus cg
combination is especially mind-blowing
to me yeah well you know i
i told the director bart i said you know
we can do this whole thing on a nice
stage in atlanta and we can be staying
at the ritz on peace street street every
night and he was like no way we need the
real if the lion has got to be cgi i
want everything else to be real and
idris and i were all for it and it shows
when you see the film because it's very
experiential you you're in the moment
you feel it you see these wide shots the
scope these vistas that are gorgeous
of africa uh and in it of course we've
got this amazing narrative around this
rogue lion which looks pretty damn real
as well those wanners are something else
too i'll throw that out there with the
lion because i know you did a lot of
research into the reality of what a
rogue lion why he becomes a rogue lion
and then what it does after this is the
animal lover in me talking but is there
any way to bring a roguelion back from
that state
oh in real life i don't know i'm sure
anything is possible but what i do know
is that
because this is a man-made phenomena
because we
as poachers divide the prides
once a
alpha male is separated from his pride
and his pride is either killed or moved
on and another alpha male now takes
control of that pride
they are not welcomed and so they end up
being kind of like these nomadic roaming
rogue lions and it is very difficult uh
to my knowledge for them to then
re-establish themselves within a pride
without major conflict i.e killing the
alpha male of an existing pride so it's
like violence begets violence really
breaks my heart to hear that but i
really appreciate the way that you don't
present the rogueline as a villain in
this movie and make sure you could feel
it even though you're rooting for the
main characters yes uh going back to the
very beginning briefly i was reading a
little bit about how jamie basically
presented the idea of i think it was
cujo but with a lion and then you kind
of had to you know fill in the guts of
the story from there during that
development process how much did it
change from the very first idea you came
to fill out that idea compared to what
we see in this final film movies always
change a lot in the development process
this is no exception but i will say at
its core was this idea that jamie had of
a a person it became a family in peril
on the run from a rogue lion which is a
man-made phenomenon that's still there
that was very much in the in the
conception of her original idea and that
is kind of what i think is helping this
to
cut through it's like you get it you
know what it is now it's a really
interesting journey that we take you on
but to me it's the perfect summer film
it is it's got real stakes got real
people got real jeopardy but it doesn't
take itself so seriously we want fun i
think i think we want fun escapism
especially right now always sign me up
for that especially fun escapism with a
tinge of jurassic park to it you caught
that my favorite movie of all the second
i saw the t-shirt i'm like i'm gonna
like this movie yeah yeah absolutely and
then there's a whole bunch peppered
throughout i was really into it yes
little bit of a sillier question for you
now i was asking it to some of the uh
the cast here but let's say you like
real you you are trapped in the middle
of nowhere in a car and there's a
rogueline going after you you can pick
two actors that you've worked with on
past films to have in that car with you
who do you pick to give yourself the
best chance of surviving the situation
that's easy it's your settlement kevin
hart that's who i'm going in there with
yes because see idris and i together can
throw kevin hart out when the lion is
even kevin we can figure out how to get
away he's going to be a snack so we need
a small snack and that would be kevin
i'm sorry bro we got to sacrifice you i
mean it is what it is law of the jungle
and it just has been in this situation
so i'm taking him there you go i mean i
feel really bad right now but that
answer tickles me i love it i have to
let you go huge congratulations and
thank you for this wild ride thank you
you